Hey everyone! We have covered revenue and we have covered costs. Now what we want to do is take a look at the firm's profit maximization and loss minimization quantities. And we're going to do that by having a look at the demand curve it faces and the marginal cost curve and average total cost curve that it faces. So let's go ahead and jump into a graph
where we're going to be looking at the competitive firm, the quantity and price on their respective axes. And we know that the competitive firm has a demand curve that is perfectly elastic. And let's give this a price of $10. And that we also know it's equal to its marginal revenue we found that out earlier. Now let's draw in a marginal cost curve that we should be familiar with. An now notice that the marginal cost curve intersects the demand / marginal revenue curve at this particular point. And let's give this some level of output, we'll call it--oh I don't know--50.
So now we have a lot of information in front of us. We know that total revenue
is our price times our quantity. So we have a price of $10 and a quantity of 50 this gives us $10 * 50 for a total revenue of $500. Let me rewrite that.
So we have $10 * 50 for total revenue of $500. So that is going to be this area
right here. The area that is a square. It is bounded by the $10 and the 50,but that doesn't tell us what our profit is going to be. What we need to know is the average total cost so that way we can figure out what our total cost are going to be. Average total cost, if you recall is just your total cost divided by your quantity. Well if I multiply this by the quantity that I have of 50 then that gives me my total cost. So now let's go in and let's add in a total cost curve and let's put it somewhere--I don't know--right down here.
So this is our average total cost curve and you'll notice that it is supposed to intersect at the minimum point with the marginal cost there. But if we want to figure out our total profit here
we need to start with the quantity of 50 go up to we hit our average total cost curve and then we're just going to march on over to our price axis and let's say that at this price we have $7. So to produce 50 units of output my average total cost is $7 per unit. If I multiply the 50 times the 7. So 50
50 as a quantity.
Times the $7 average total cost that gives me $350 in my total cost. So the area that I'm going to shade in a right now this area is going to be our total cost.
And the area that I'm shading in now
is our total profit.
All right that's our total profit. So our total profit just to calculate it out is the total revenue minus total cost which is $500 - $350. And this gives us $150 as our total profit. And one thing just to remember marginal revenue equals marginal cost is the profit maximization level where that's the amount of output we want to produce. We don't want to produce any less. We don't want to produce any more because that would reduce our total profit that we have here. So wherever your marginal revenue equals your marginal cost is where you will maximize your profit.
Now also this is where you will minimize your losses. So let's draw in another diagram
where we're going to look at a loss minimization. Here's our quantity. Here's our price. And let's keep the demand curve and marginal revenue curve at a price of $10. We're going to draw in this marginal cost curve again and we had at this price we were selling 50 units. But now let's put the average total cost above
our demand curve. Above this price being charged. Look what happens. Let's start at 50 and we're going to march our way up to this average total cost curve. And then we're going to go over.
And we're going to put some new price here--let's call it $15 instead of $10. So now our economic loss is going to be, or excuse me our total cost, is going to be this total area right here. And our total profit was just the area that was right here. So now we can see there's a difference between our total revenue and our total cost and that we have an economic loss--that's going to be this area. So let's just shade that is nice and neat there. And let's calculate out what our economic loss is going to be. So we have the difference between the prices of $15 and $10. So let's go ahead and put $5 as a difference there. And we're going to multiply that by the 50 units that were selling and this is going to give me an economic loss of
- $250.
Our total cost are going to be $750 let's just write that in. Total cost for $750. Our total revenue was the $10 * 50 which gives us $500. If we were to move this way or we were to move that way then what we would see is that this economic loss would actually be even higher, so we definitely don't want to move beyond the profit maximization / lost minimization point right here where my marginal cost equals marginal revenue. Now what happens? Well some firms are going to continue to have these economic losses in the short run. And they may make a decision to leave altogether in the long run.
You can see the same thing with the profit maximization. Here, some firms or potential entrants are going to see this and they're going to go: Hey! They're making an economic profit. Let me enter into this market. And eventually what we will see is that this price will change, this average total cost will change, and that is going to cause these firms to have no economic profit in the long run. Same thing here. Firms will leave and these firms that are existing will have no more economic losses. They'll just be stuck with a normal profit. More on that later. Hope you enjoyed it and we'll catch you in our next one.